thinking of our bathroom i remember i
this isn't really much of a story but
that was the worst time someone asked me
for a photo i was queuing up to take a
[ __ ] at ax
i kid you not right i'm taking a [ __ ]
and the guy
so you've got to like line up because
the [ __ ] toilets are tiny in the uh
ax convention yeah yeah
and uh the guy's having a piss on the
the cubicle
another keep it called the urinal and uh
i'm just on my phone he turns around
he's like
sea dog yo what's up thinking that like
that's it because we're a [ __ ] toilet
yeah yeah
can i take a photo i'm like you didn't
even wash your hand
near me like still zipping up his pants
no
we can't take a picture right now i'm
taking my stick of [ __ ]
in the toilet with other people pissing
at the same time it's filled and i feel
like i'm the [ __ ]
yeah yeah because now everyone's looking
at us and i'm like are you kidding me
dude
i'm not i've had i've had a similar
thing but i was actually at the urinal
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah dick in hand
and
i've been there and the dude directly
next to me was like yo joey what's up
and i'm like can you not see that penis
in my head right yeah
my stream would instant stop at that
moment
i could i think mine actually got faster
because i'm like i'm pretty sure this
guy's about to ask a photo no i'm not
about to get a photo taken
my hand because like i didn't know how
to react to that because i remember this
the exact thing came the exact same
thing happened to me when i was in the
urinal
and it's the case where there are like
five urinals in a row yeah and i was
in like one of the one at the end yeah
and i knew something was wrong
when a guy chooses the one right next to
me and i'm just like
here we go
like my first instinct is like why are
you standing in the urinal next to me
there are
you know if you're not a guy there's an
unwritten
etiquette to like toilets where if if
the urinal
next to you is like free and there's
like more urinals other than one excuse
free
basic interest you don't go to the one
next to the person always already
pissing you you don't want to be that
creepy that's
basic basic urinal etiquette yeah you
don't want to be that creep who's like
i don't want to look at his penis but i
want to look at him
look at his penis yeah so um i i
finished my
um i finished my business and for some
reason he asked for a handshake i'm like
can you at least let me wash my hands
first man
so what was your like most like weird or
just strange convention experience
before you were a youtuber like
or before you met khan
um i would say like actually it was
probably
i was doing like say voice acting online
you know i wasn't like massive at that
point
i was a senior in high school and i
actually worked at the maid cafe at
anime milwaukee
of course you did of course of course
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah i couldn't
you didn't even need to tell me
i just assumed yeah and then um oh my
god i really hope this guy doesn't watch
us
so i was just kind of like we had 10
minutes off right so i was going to go
get some water or something
and this guy is just like wow uh are you
working at the maid cafe and i
like had my maid on me all the same
uniform i'm like no [ __ ] yeah
i was like yeah and he's like okay and
i'm like okay and i was on the escalator
and then he turned away and i'm like and
then i turned away
and then when we were closing up for the
night this guy comes up and he hands me
like this dollar that he origami into a
shirt
and um he's like do you think this is a
really cool like thing and i'm like
he's like you can keep that you can keep
that dollar i'm like
you're frothing at this finally
roughing up the loins i was like oh [ __ ]
he gave me a dollar
and then um so i was just sitting down
waiting for like to get my parents
started like waiting for the night to
end
and then he just sat down and then he
just didn't say anything and then
like like 20 minutes goes by and i'm
like i'm gonna go in the back and i stay
there for two hours and he's still there
waiting
and so i actually had the manager go out
and yell at him to get out and i feel
bad because he's actually really shocked
like he thought i was genuinely could
come out be like when's our date
and um i mean i guess that's not like
the most creepiest thing like
that that doesn't sound like sounds kind
of rapey yeah that's a telerate
but it was definitely something i look
back and i'm like i kind of feel bad but
another way
he probably could have been a bit better
about it i swear like i don't know what
it is about anime conventions that just
turns anime fans into just monkeys like
i don't know i think it's just a lack
like a lot of young people
and a lot of old people who lack social
skills
yeah you know not to be mean but i think
a lot of people who go to it
there's a good thing people who go to
make conventions who don't really like
you know
who socially yeah they don't really
socialize too much outside of you know
maybe
playing games online and yeah i don't
know i feel like
i think there's a lot of who just
assumed that because you like the same
thing as me
yeah yeah i can't do anything with you
yeah you'll be okay with it i'm yeah i'm
definitely
glad that i don't know that i when i was
younger i didn't
interact with people because i feel like
i would have been weird i'm i'm like i'm
i'm kind of glad i didn't go to anime
conventions that early as well because
like seeing how many stuff is coming out
about the smash community and stuff
i can only imagine what's happening oh
there's like animals
i can easily get based on what i've seen
in private like people do
and i make conventions now i can only
imagine how i'm honestly surprised the
smash convention was called out
before the anime convention scene yeah
yeah i'm sure there's
horrible stories that go behind the
scenes i think i think the problem is
with anime mentions a lot of the time
it's like
not like the celebrities like the
organizers sometimes yeah yeah
speculating and i mean there are stories
obviously yeah and it's kind of hard to
it's kind of hard to it sucks but like
cancel someone who no one cares about
yeah
i mean like yeah when you cancel like a
community like smash you've got like
these big names right and yeah
you when you bring it out it's like a i
cared about that person yeah it's like
dude the event organizer of x-con in
your area is a rapist
who's that like yeah there's the console
on them
at least yeah it's bad i mean i'm not
trying to make light of any of that i
mean
it's really [ __ ] up but i mean that's
kind of how it is right it's unfortunate
um